avec thierry laurent directeur de
cabinet du préfet des yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous déjà en
ce pont de l'ascension où la tentation
pourrait être grande de partir à plus de
100 kilomètres de son domicile pour le
week-end ce qui est formellement
interdit aussi à observer moins de
prudence avec eux ces beaux jours qui
reviennent est ce que les yvelinois ont
fait preuve de prudence jusqu'à présent
sur le déplacement et sur les routes
globalement oui la police la gendarmerie
étaient présents pour exercer de
contrôle quelques infractions ont été
relevées mais la plupart des
automobilistes disposait des
attestations nécessaires pour leurs
déplacements et penser week-end de
l'ascension justement et de la pentecôte
qui va qui va suivre est ce que la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre dans
les éliminer et plus forte en ce moment
cette mobilisation est forte depuis le
début du confinement elle s'est
poursuivie avec l'un des confidents
elle se poursuivra évidemment pendant ce
week-end prolongé
mais on observe notamment sur les
autoroutes un trafic moins élevé que
l'année dernière à la même date le
déconfinement qui est effectif partout
en france et dans les yvelines depuis le
11 mai quel premier bilan vous voudrez
c'est après deux semaines justement de
ce début de déconfinement il est encore
trop tôt pour évidemment on dresser un
bilan complet les choses globalement se
passe dans un bon esprit est d'abord un
esprit de responsabilité de chacun de
nous de chaque acteur qu'ils soient
publics ou privés qui participent à ce
déconfinement pense aux élus aux maires
qui ont beaucoup travaillé pour la
remise la réouverture des écoles par
exemple avec les enseignants pour
convaincre aussi les parents de remettre
des enfants dans mes dans les écoles
donc ceux des compliments il est
progressif et se construit sur la
confiance et dans le dialogue avec
chacun sur les comportements aussi
les choses globalement dans le bon sens
il n'y a pas d'incidents signalés dans
les transports en commun bien au
contraire l immense majorité des usagers
portent leur masse une force de l'ordre
par exemple ont pas besoin de verbaliser
pour des non port de masque est ce que
ce n'est pas de l'homme ce n'est pas le
cas vous évoquez justement le cas des
écoles 1 55% des villes et villages du
département ont entamé une une démarche
de réouverture de leur école ce qui
représente environ 920 établissements
dans les yvelines
nous relations cette semaine le cas de
deux cas suspects de kobe de 19 à il
encourt qui ont entraîné la fermeture
des écoles vibrante et aussi de l'école
de lavilledieu est ce qu'on en sait plus
sur ces cas suspects ce que d'autres
situations qui sont similaires ont été
rencontrés dans le département des
yvelines depuis la réouverture de ces
écoles alors sur les deux cas que vous
évoquez
elle encourt l'enfant et puis le
l'enseignante qui présentait des
symptômes ont été testés ces tests
révèlent ni enfant ni l'enseignante ne
sont porteurs du duc au vide et donc
l'école pourra ouvrir normalement dès
lundi il ya d'autres cas et c'est normal
toute la stratégie sanitaire de
déconfinement vise à multiplier les
tests pour justement prendre en compte
cette situation donc naturel que les cas
nouveaux continuent à apparaître et
qu'il soit traité par la rs par les
médecins traitants et puis qu'on prenne
ensuite quand on est dans une école par
exemple des décisions en lien avec
l'inspection d'académie et le maire de
la commune concernée
on rappelle que les yvelines sont
classés comme département rouge sur la
carte de déconfinement en france même si
on sait que la circulation du virus en
tout cas depuis les dernières données
étaient au vert c'est plutôt sur la
fonction hospitalière qui que les
chiffres sont moins bons elle reste
plutôt forte avec 630 patients
hospitalisés plus de 40 en réanimation
sur le
le département quelle est la situation
actuelle dans les yvelines est ce que
les dernières données sont plutôt
rassurantes plutôt inquiétante
ce sont les données que vous venez
d'évoquer les chiffres et développiez
effectivement la circulation du virus
d'après les chiffres que nous avons paré
modéré il est encore trop tôt pour
mesurer l'effet sanitaire du confinement
vous connaissez nous connaissons tous
maintenant que dd d'incubation de qui va
jusqu'à 14 jours donc on n'est pas
encore en mesure de voir cet effet
compte tenu de la date d confinement le
11 mai dernier
quoi qu'il en soit quels que soient les
chiffres
la vigilance reste de mise et la
vigilance c'est le respect des restes
barrière c'est le port du masque
lorsqu'on n'est pas en mesure de
respecter la distanciation sociale en
particulier dans les transports en
commun bien sûr mais ça peut être le cas
dans les commerces par exemple même s'il
a le port du masque dès que recommandée
mais il l'est et vivement on va parler
des commerces dans un instant juste un
mot sur cette cellule d'appui et de
suivi pour l'accueil de 19 qui a été
lancé le 12 mai dans les yvelines
elle a pour objectif d'identifier et
d'accompagner les malades et leurs
proches le premier bilan que vous
dressez sûr sur cette cellule qui est
installé à versailles allait-il cette
cellule vraiment partie de la stratégie
de confinement qui repose sur trois
piliers des tests est-ce que massif dès
que les personnes ont des symptômes et
donc je ne peux qu'encourager vos
téléspectateurs à consulter leur médecin
lorsqu'ils ont un doute ils seront
testés ils auront la réponse
le deuxième pilier de sa stratégie c'est
la recherche des contacts ces faits soit
par le médecin traitant soit par
l'assurance maladie
enfin la rs dans les cas les plus
complexes pour proposer aux personnes
qui ont été en contact en contact avec
une personne malade de s'isoler elle
aussi dans la plupart des cas à l'heure
à leur domicile
et puis le dernier point c'est justement
l'isolément qui doit être consenti c'est
toujours sur la base du volontariat qui
doit être expliquée il faut expliquer à
chacun de nos concitoyens à qui on
demande de ceux de rester à son domicile
quel est l'enjeu de cet isolement
et puis qui doit être accompagnée et
c'est ce que fait cette cellule
départementale qui va appeler chaque
jour les personnes isolées pour prendre
de leurs nouvelles s'assurer que leur
état ne se débattent pas et qui peut
aussi leur proposer un certain nombre de
services d'accompagnement dans les zones
denses a peut-être du portage de course
ça peut être dans les cas les plus
compliqués un hébergement à l'hôtel
lorsque c'est nécessaire mais c'était
largement le tag n'est pas la règle
la règle c'est isolement chez soi quand
c'est possible on vous explique quels
sont les gestes barrière le cas échéant
un médecin un infirmier un travailleur
social peut se déplacer au domicile pour
expliquer comment vivre chez soi sans
contaminer ses proches en portant un
masque en ayant une hygiène notamment
des mains irréprochable en expliquant
comment partager une salle de bain quand
on est malade sans prendre le risque de
contaminer ses proches alors vous
évoquez aussi le cas des commerces 1 qui
ont rouvert depuis le 11 mai à
l'exception des bars cafés et
restaurants pour lesquelles une décision
sera prise à la fin mai par le
gouvernement les centres commerciaux de
plus de 40 mille mètres carrés reste
également fermées sauf sur autorisation
du préfet des yvelines on a vu dans les
derniers jours la réouverture de
l'espace saint quentin notamment à
montigny le bretonneux est-ce qu'on
pourrait voir pareille décision pour
d'autres centres commerciaux d'autres
grands centres commerciaux des yvelines
je pense à à vélizy 2 à vélizy 2 pardon
à à parly 2 est-ce qu'on pourrait voir
pareille décision dans les prochains
jours alors son espace saint quentin à
saint quentin en yvelines on n'est pas
dans la même situation que vélizy 2 et
paris deux ils deviennent règles sur ses
centres commerciaux c'est une surface
commerciale utile de plus de 40
kilomètres carrés autour d'un mcdo c'est
la définition d'un centre commercial
donc on n'était pas dans cette situation
là sur l'espace saint quentin ce qui lui
a permis de réunir en revanche deux
centres de très grands centres
commerciaux du département seront sa
situation des visites de et parly 2 qui
reste fermé tant que nous restons en
zone rouge où tant que le texte qui
prévoit la fermeture de ses grands
centres commerciaux dans le département
n'évolue pas c'est la même chose pour
les parcs et jardins pas de réouverture
prévue
vu que le département des yvelines est
placé en rouge ya plusieurs maires qui
demandent la réouverture de ses parcs et
jardins exactement mais le texte est
très clair c'est une décret sur de
déconfinement qui a prévu la fermeture
de ces parcs jardins espaces verts
aménagés dans les zones urbaines des
départements en zone rouge c'est à dire
que les parcs situés dans les zones
rurales du département sont ouverts mais
ça ne peut pas être le cas pour le
moment dans des zones urbaines du
département alors dans le même temps il
ya des domaines je pense à à breteuil à
dampierre en evil qui ont soit rouvert
soit qu'ils vont rouvrir dans les
prochains jours ces accès des décisions
qui se prennent au cas par cas là pour
le coup vous ils sont considérés comme
de petits musées ces domaines exactement
en lien avec les maires avec les
exploitants le préfet a autorisé
l'ouverture d'une trentaine de petits
musées dans le département devoti le
château de breteuil à l'instant cela
fait aussi partie des échanges que nous
avons dès lors que l'exploitant nous
expliquent comment ils mettent en place
des gestes barrières les distanciation
sociale qui permette une reprise de
cette activité qui à la fois importante
pour les établissements eux mêmes mais
qui est aussi importante pour nos
concitoyens après deux mois de
confinement de pouvoir sursis gêné dans
des lieux culturels c'est tout à fait
essentiel et avec le respect de ses
gestes barrières de ces distanciation
c'est aujourd'hui possible
un dernier mot pour clôturer cet
entretien tiré lors en soit les lieux de
culte le conseil d'état a redonné leur
réouverture pour la semaine prochaine
comment cela va s'organiser dans les
yvelines est ce que ce sont chaque lieu
de culte qui décident de leur
réouverture de leur côté ce qui est un
travail mené avec la préfecture
d'abord une intense et celle du décret
qui va fixer le cadre de cette
réouverture l'importance des réunions
qui pourront le cas échéant être
organisé dans ces lieux ça nous le
verrons cours du week-end à la parution
du décret ensuite c'est dans le dialogue
évidemment avec les représentants des
cultes que chaque que chacun prendra la
décision
nous avons nous serons attentifs c'est
évidemment au respect des gestes
barrières des distanciation sociale dans
les lieux de plus pendant les cérémonies
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
pendant toute la période de confinement
l'esprit de responsabilité des
représentants des cultes a été permanent
nous avons été façon continue en
dialogue avec les représentants des
cultes présentant département les choix
qu'ils font ce sont des choix éminemment
responsable donc nous n'avons pas
d'inquiétude sur ce sursaut dialogue qui
se mettra en place sur ce qui sortira
merci thierry laurent d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous joindre
et je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines